in a way the Martian is just the
hangover in space because they left the
guy behind one of the things that they
did really well in the movie was the
time it takes to communicate with Mars
we've got an incoming message mine takes
like 15 minutes just to send a signal to
Mars and 15 minutes to get a signal back
I'm a botanist the terraforming was
probably one of the most accurate things
in the movie growing potatoes with poop
Martian soil water from exploding rocket
fuel that is all totally feasible anyone
gets lost in my suits limiting you ready
ready the funny thing about the tarp at
the end was the movie kind of
contradicted itself it said oh the
atmosphere is not that thick we can just
put a tarp on the top but then there was
a giant sand storm that knocked over a
rocket and impaled Matt Damon with a
tiny spear so which one is it guys Mars
does have storms but they're just not
quite as violent as depicted in the
movie there is an atmosphere there is
wind sometimes the dust blows around get
dust bunnies and whatnot but there are
not these giant violent storms that can
knock over a spaceship I really loved
the moment when they dug up the old Mars
rover and used it to start
communications back with the planet
Earth what a great call back to stuff
that JPL actually did in the 90s 1200
kilometres in diameter bearing 24 point
41 degrees it was really nice to see
some females in lead important roles in
this movie I think there's a lot of
really fantastic real-life female role
models in the space program and in other
places throughout NASA we need more but
it's nice to see them on the big screen
if we mess up the earth gravity assists
we die lots of people think it's time to
start trying to colonize other planets
like Mars and it may be important to
begin to explore and look to those
places you can't forget that we have to
take care of the planet we already live
on we're not going to get all seven
billion people off the planet to Mars
and in the meantime ours is kind of
getting devastated so pay attention to
home but look to the Stars too